[Captions by Y Translator]
Fog juice is used
for making the special effect
where you create clouds, mist, or fog.
Today, we're going to try
boiling a whole gallon of it
and see what kind of result we get.
[Music]
What happens when you boil
an entire gallon of fog juice?
I don't know,
but I want to find out,
so that's what
we're doing today.
The idea is simple.
We'll try boiling or burning
a small portion of the fog juice,
and see what kind of effect we get.
If it's anything that we like,
we're going to take a whole gallon of it,
pour it into a steel pot,
put the pot in a big old foundry
and crank up the heat.
Some of the ingredients
in fog juice don't boil
at as low of a temperature as water.
Water, of course boils
at a 100 degrees Celsius
or 212 degrees Fahrenheit.
Some of the ingredients
in the fog juice don't boil until
5 or 600 degrees Fahrenheit,
so we're going to use
a little bit more heat
than usual to try and really
get this to vaporize.
What exactly goes
into these fog fluid recipes
is a little bit of a trade secret,
but there's often water,
there's some glycerin,
there's a whole bunch of different
compounds based on ethylene glycol.
[Music]
We're going to start off
with a relatively small amount.
Pour that in,
then watch what happens.
So, so far, it seems
like it's just steaming.
Normal steam from water,
but I think there is still
a lot of water in it.
And the water in it is going
to keep the temperature down
until it's all evaporated,
and at that point I'm hoping
the other chemicals will sort of,
do their thing where they vaporize
and we'll see if we start
getting thicker smoke.
I think we already
are getting thicker smoke.
In fact, up in the air it's
starting to be quite visible.
Now the way that fog fluid works is
that it vaporizes.
And normally, this is done
inside a machine.
It pulls some of the fluid out
in a very small quantity,
applies it to a heating element,
that vaporizes it,
it sprays it out the front,
and when it hits the cooler air
it condenses into the thick fog
that we're used to seeing.
This is happening in a little bit
of a different method right now
because we are just
using a pot on a stove
and so it stays really hot.
And it's probably not condensing
until 6 to 10 feet above our pot.
Now it's bubbling
interestingly.
[Music]
Part of our pot is
literally red hot.
[Music]
We're definitely
getting a thicker fog now.
Oh, and it caught on fire.
Fascinating.
[Music]
It's off the heat.
Pot is obviously still very warm,
and we've still got fog rising up.
We've definitely started filling the dome,
and it's got--
If you've been around fog machines,
there's a smell that they have,
and it's got that smell filling
the dome at this point.
So I would say our small-scale test,
we are getting some fog coming
out of that fog juice
as we boil it and burn it.
I don't know if it's necessarily
as efficient as it is when you put it
into a fog machine.
Those things do a pretty good job
of using their fog juice
for quite a while,
but this is definitely faster.
So I think what we need to do
is upgrade a little bit,
and we're just going to try
doing the whole gallon
and see how much it'll fill the dome.
And then also,
in the top of our dome
there is a small little oculus ring.
That allows for airflow,
and some light to get in,
although most of the light
comes in through the door.
But we want to see
if we get fog kind of pouring up
out of that circle in the top.
Not only that, but we are also going
to be using our giant metal foundry,
which so far has had,
sadly, very little use.
I think we poured some liquid
nitrogen down into it once
but now we get to actually fire it up
with something inside it.
And hopefully it's just going
to get that whole pot blazing
hot as fast as possible.
But the hope is that we get
a lot of smoke out of this.
A gallons worth of
fog fluid out of this.
Let's give it a try.
[Music]
Feels like it has plenty.
Throw this on to see
if it helps, or hurts.
[Music]
Oh, suddenly some fog
is coming up out of that.
[Music]
It is all boiling
rather marvelously.
You can see how much
of this is just water
that needs to boil off and...
It's getting lower.
But water creates a little bit of vapor,
whereas the other chemicals create
a lot more vapor.
[Music]
It's very shallow now,
there's only like an inch
of liquid at the bottom of that.
And it's definitely
getting smokier.
Like you're now hazy.
Oh, I think we're hitting
the critical point.
This is looking more.
[Music]
Man, that is crazy
how little is left.
Maybe 3/4, or a half an inch
at the bottom of that pot now.
[Music]
We may finally have started
to boil off all the water.
[Music]
Oh, I think we might have started
to actually ignite it inside there too.
Our fog juice, or what's
left of it has actually caught
on fire inside the pot.
Bigger flames than I thought
were going to happen.
That is well, and truly on fire.
It's pretty smoky in here.
So now, I'm going to take a knife
and perforate it and then
try and run and jump through it.
Boiling fog juice does not work as well
as just putting fog juice in a fog machine.
That's what they're designed for,
it's all been carefully formulated
and measured to work
with that system
to disperse it into the air.
You do get some nice thick fog
when you heat it up,
but I think it just gets too thick.
Usually when it's applied
into a fog machine, it's in just
the right amount that it can vaporize
before it's thrown out in the machine
and it then condenses.
You don't have nearly
that much control when
you just light it on fire.
It's a cool thing to see and do,
but I bet we would get
a lot more fog out of a gallon
if we just put it into a machine.
We've got a little bit
more time right now.
We're going to do
some more Q&A.
You have asked us
some questions.
We're going to try and
answer some of them for you.
Alright.
We now have a question
from Vedant Sakhuja, I am so sorry.
I'm pronouncing that wrong
in nine different ways.
Sakhuja, Sahulya.
I'm very sorry that I
do not know how to say that.
He asked, what is
your filming gear?
That depends, If you ask me,
our filming gear is a camera,
a microphone, and some lights.
But I don't think that's quite
the answer you're looking for.
So we're going to turn this over
to our cameraman who's gonna give
you actual answers
about what we use.
Mark?
Cool, so the main camera that
we use is the Sony A6500.
We love this camera,
it's cheap.
If we happen to destroy it,
it's not that expensive to replace it
and buy a new one.
It's lightweight and we can
put it in a lot of places
that we probably couldn't put
a larger camera in.
We have gone through a couple
different kind of microphones.
We mainly use these lav mics,
it's a Sony lav mic
and hooked to a Sony field recorder.
We love the the sound of the audio,
it's really easy to sync up in post.
So on the camera,
we have a Rode videomicro,
and it's mainly for getting ambient
sounds, like, the sounds of explosions,
or something boiling.
On top of the camera,
we have a small HD monitor that I use to
be able to see what I'm recording instead
of on that tiny little LCD that's built into the camera.
It's just nice having
something a little bit brighter
and larger for making sure
I have everything in focus.
And to specify, smallHD is
actually the brand of the monitor.
That's not just a description,
that it's small and high definition.
Yep.
The lens on my camera is a Zeiss 24
millimeter 1.8 aperture prime lens.
And it is the main lens that we use,
I do have quite a few other lenses.
I love this Zeiss
1.8 aperture lens.
It helps with low light
video shots that we need.
The lights that we use
in our studio are pretty cheap
that you can just find them on Amazon.
We can link them down
in the description below.
Yeah, we do use other cameras.
We really like using the
Sony RX100 Mark V.
It's a great camera
it's small, again, portable.
We have actually had this really close
to like molten aluminum exploding onto it.
On the lens, you can see
we actually have a couple
of pock marks from where molten aluminum
and molten brass have splashed onto it
and melted the glass
but it still works great
and we love it.
We love using GoPros as well.
They are excellent for putting up
even closer to the action.
For example, this GoPro
right here is totally
melted on the top.
We had molten brass melt the top
of this GoPro but it still
works which is very impressive.
So for editing, we,
as a team use PremierePro.
It's excellent for being able
to start off editing on one machine.
I'll upload the footage
to Dropbox and we
have editors that are not local,
download the footage
and the project file and just
be able to start working right
from where I left off.
Hey, thank you Vedant
for your question.
Guys, that's all for today.
But the fun doesn't end here that box
at the top will take you directly
to our most recent video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you haven't joined the club
yet just hit this bomb
and you'll be subscribed to the channel.
So you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we'll see you
on the next one.
Talk to you then.